in my bag take a piece
not brought to you by my people anak
Edibles what's that little [__] piece
they got to eat the whole side I got to
survive the [__] that's a little
[__] piece eat that [__] C we're
training for the Olympics over here
we're going deep olymp go the olmpics
are being H right here this piece you
[__] give me that little piece B that's
for fidgets take this piece here give me
that that's for me take that why is that
funy why do you have the small piece cuz
I'm already over my carbohydrate limit
you know what's funny I didn't think
we're going to put dent in that backpack
but shit's going pretty well we ain't
[__] around tonight an the Edibles
dropped off a bag of death no I told you
delicious as [__] with some it's way
better than the other kind oh my god
with some milk in that [__] you
dip these in the middle of the nightly
who's better than you you'll sleep like
a [__] baby probably about half an
hour you'll be but you didn't bring milk
you we have we have room temperature
water I got some milk in my nut how
about that one
fory we need some th THC milk milk to go
with this I still got
it you can't stop the DS there's nothing
you can do about it be back what's
happening me Tron nothing I just got
back myself around 12:30 from West Palm
Beach took a nap brought my ass to North
Hollywood to party with you guys do we
have a surprise guest this time which
just going to show oh yeah remember
Franklin came the last time that was
embarrassing as [__] I'm sorry about
that no that was fun man it was
something different you [__] people
how was West Palm Beach it was fun man
sold out shows I was working with
Whitney Cummings and uh lots of [__]
people there you know Valentine's Day is
never the most fun in the world but it
was still pretty [__] I had a great
time in Austin there were great [__]
crowds and uh Austin is a great City
great people seen oky spooky seen your
boy Andrew Miller Andrew Miller and his
girlfriend looking good he gave me a
little devil with a [__] long tongue
so you could massage your muffler with
it and have a good time are you sure so
I could did he make it so I can massage
my muffler yeah yeah he made your
special tool you know just for you
Austin's a great [__] City I was very
fortunate to be down there for
Valentine's Day and it's great to be
home I'm home for [__] 10 days you
know like that's the best to get home
yeah to just get home and deoxidize and
today was a light day you know not a big
day today I went to hegan Jiu-Jitsu you
know and I'm was thinking about you
today I was thinking about you last
night I called
you then you told me you're on the road
with Whitney you also go on the road
if I'm local I'll give you a you know
you're one of those guys that you're
right there right and in your mind you
get frustrated cuz I was there like
people [__] calling me and [__]
people think I'm funny right what's
going on I come [__] uh where's Robin
Williams in this new show you know what
I'm saying who's [__] where's my new
TV show it's just a it's one of those
things you got to roll with though and
I'm sure cuz I've been lower on the
totem pole than this and I'll fantasize
about the times when I was even lower a
totem pole like ah that was fun though
rolling around Hollywood like before I
was getting getting paid or whatever
just [__] doing shows just for fun
and I'm sure I'll feel the same way
about this part of my life too where
it's like ah should be headlining a lot
more I'm ready to make the jump but you
know it's weird you're just waiting for
that push you just need that little push
and for me it was the longest yard where
people now were like all right now we
have to headline them so you understand
like there's little things you got to do
but today I was I went to Jiu-Jitsu and
and I went and hegan was there and one
thing that hegan teaches that nobody he
teaches big guy Jiu-Jitsu uhuh you know
if you go to cabrin who's a great school
he teaches ji- Jitsu for guys like you
it's 170 lbs right there's Baron bolos
and more [__] spiders and all this
other [__] with big guy Jiu-Jitsu like
me and Lee he wants you to conserve
energy so every move has to be Swift and
when he sat in that chair where you were
there he was talking about how Jiu-Jitsu
really en enriches your life after you
start thinking about it like you start
thinking about the moves and I was
thinking about it today
how comedy is great at this point for me
you know and you'll be there also
because you're on the right path this is
the beginning of the journey opening up
for people different people calling you
people calling you for avails you know
somebody submitting your tape for coning
and even if you don't get it it's fine
somebody submitted your [__] tape
that means you're in the game yeah I
remember having a talk with reney one I
he had been on 20 auditions and he was
in producer sessions and he was never
going to book a show and I go you're on
the path right it's just it's just you
just got a fall you know yeah and as a
comic I know that 10 years
ago you know standup wise I'm working
today the way I am because of a road I
got on 10 years ago right I think about
two years before I got off the blow I
got serious about writing and even
though those last two years of blow were
dark for me yeah I was still writing
some good stuff stuff I just wasn't
performing at late like I would think of
something and I and then I got off the
blow and those jokes started working for
me but it was two years are right in a
closet you know that you need to get a
jump and like there was so much wasted
time when I first moved to Los Angeles
right is what I'm trying to say if I
could do it all over again I wasted 10
years of time hanging out talking to
people about Dick yeah you know when I
could have been utilizing time those two
hours there you could have been writing
yeah it's amazing what you're getting
those two hours and if and in the
beginning I used to just sit with a
notebook and put Lis at flying Jew and
sit there for two hours looking at that
trying to think of a joke do you
understand me right then I figured out
wait a
second if I write out a story it'll make
it easier for me to write that joke
because I'm massaging the muscle I'm
using the muscle right that's when I
really started moving forward in my life
so I started writing stories and I
started writing more jokes and but it's
where you're at right now you're in a
beautiful spot I know man and I'm to the
spot that you're talking about right now
where I'm working on it every day
whereas when I first started out I
didn't know about the discipline you met
four guys and went for coffee you drank
and you talked about yeah well I wrote
this joke after the news you wrote two
jokes you took a nap [__] the
girlfriend once you start making it the
priority and I I have to do it first
thing in the morning get up have my
coffee that's what I do some writing
it's amazing how much even if you only
have 15 minutes how much better that is
than nothing nothing as long as it's
about every day it's about doing it
every day same with that class you're
taking what's the most frustating part
as like a because in normal jobs you
have like a yearly review and they're
like you have to work on this or you get
promoted we get a Daily Review as a
comedian that's true but we get an
audience review you don't get like a a
boss review you get both you get like a
customer review but not a so many times
club Owners give their review too really
of course it's not even asked for it's
not even valid but they'll give it you
know that's crazy yeah yeah yeah they
will [__] say you guys are restaurant
managers calm the [__] down all of a
sudden they become all of a sudden they
become [__] bud Freeman yeah and
that's when my [__] shuts off I know
exactly who's Bud Freeman I know who's
faking the funk they always talk [__]
about the last guy that was there a week
before they always find something to
talk [__] about of course they're not
talking stuff about us when we leave
exactly yeah they love
you so they run that game
and we run ours exactly they run their
game and we run ours you know and and
and it works somewhere in the middle it
works as a comic at one point you go
home and you go yeah I have friends that
are making a lot more than this why am I
making this it's all about it's a
business you might say I have friends
that are not funnier as I am and get a
lot more money it's about numbers at the
end of the week it's drink sold versus
anything they don't give a [__] if they
sell $10,000 tickets and people go there
and nobody lasts her out it's out of
their [__] hands right they sold 20
[__] thousand million drinks you
follow me so it's a business and that's
what Young Comics don't realize man I'm
killing at the store how come I'm not
headlining out there they think it's a
funny contest because they think it's a
funny contest I thought I had the same
concept going on for years you know I
knew guys that would [__] avoid me
you know like [__] him we don't follow
him we don't put him on a show you know
when I get to a club the guy would say
hey man I tried to put you on this room
but the headline of booked right he
don't want a dirty guy but he didn't
want to follow you he brought a guy that
was dirtier than you but you know little
things you know you sit there and you
get it were you ever pressure to be like
more Hispanic no no no no no you know
you have moments in your head where you
doubt yourself and you go well maybe
I'll try to sell it Spanish but I'm
going tell you something they Feel the
Funk they know who the [__] you are as
soon as and if you don't know who the
[__] you are they'll let you know no
that's when you get no laughs until you
get your voice you don't get the laughs
that you
really you just scrapping for anything
you get laughs you get laughs you get
laughs you get ton of laughs but there's
a different laugh when you're really
you're you're writing for your voice
when you see Bill Burr he's writing for
his voice that's it that's it yeah once
you figure out who you are that's then
everything applies it might not be the
funniest joke in the world but the fact
that people know who you are they're
like oh yeah that's a real thought from
this real guy is that why sometimes I'll
think you had a good set and you'll be
pissed off not like sometimes you've
talked about because you forgot to say
something but sometimes you think like
the laughs aren't genuine is it not
genuine or is it just not as hard as it
could be I didn't do as good as I could
have done I [__] around or I did
something wrong I came out the wrong way
it this sometimes a comic come out and
he might step or say something or just a
little bit of ego and you shut the
audience s you know I never understood
the comic going back and forth with the
customer and arguing and calling him a
[__] I never understood that
because you you stopping the show you
got to work yourself out of that show
don't don't think I didn't do it I'm not
saying I didn't do it I [__] did it
that's how you [__] learn not to do
it you know I used to talk I I picked up
that New York horrible Habit in '94
right crowd workor and stuff yeah how
you doing that's a horrible Habit to get
involved in yeah hor every [__]
occupation has a horrible habit when you
play basketball and you're a forward the
worst thing you can do is put that ball
back down on the floor and dribble it
and go back up with it grab it and
release it that's it every time you
dribble that ball the defense comes to
you it's a [__] magnet every
occupation has a [__] no no would
stand up to me to me that I got caught
in it I got caught in it for three or
four years I got caught in it till I
moved to LA and I realized in La is it's
not going to pan out you get away with
it 1 Night at the impr at 11:30 at the
store at 1 but you're not going to get
away with at 8:30 it's only going to go
so [__] far hey how you doing where
you from did you shave that [__] will
not [__] fly at 9:45 definely and
it's definitely not going to be on the
tonight's show yeah so definely not
going be working the bleachers you just
lose it and once they come to see you
and you do that bam that's it they walk
it's really [__] they
walk so it's you learn different things
along the way I got I was doing comedy
for five [__] years with no idea like
most people at three years have [__]
got an agent and [__] and five years I
was still lost [__] lost it is weird
as a viewer to see uh crowd work in a
special cuz sometimes when you're at the
store it is it can get funny because you
can actually see them but I've seen a
few specials where they have like
substantial crowd work it's like I'm not
I you can't you can barely see the
person it's here there it's the camera
from the
uh the show with Tracy Morgan and the
chick they talk to you here then it
bounces over here then it bounces back
that's an aveng guard camera work don't
work for [__] stand up right that
lost of you going to him you just lost
him you just lost a viewer at home you
just broke his [__] concentration I
never figured it out either but man I
picked that habit in New York doing open
mics in '94 that's you know what that
habits from what
laziness well it's also like a New York
standard too like almost everybody does
crowd work what laziness because it's
it's quick laughs it's quick and you
could get into something and it's a 5050
it's a way to make a connection it seems
like a magic trick sometimes people like
wow you're really [__] quick
meanwhile he's told that joke 15 billion
times it's a setup he knows how to set
it up he knows what he's doing what
would you say if there's a comedian
listening who does a lot of crow work is
it is there nothing good that comes from
it or well some people are Master's at
it Jimmy Brogan's a master at it yeah I
think Ian bag's a master at it the
Master's at it rick Ingram's pretty good
at it you know but it goes so
far it goes so far because the standard
is for you to go up there and tell me
something that I don't know right you
know if you're on a if you're doing a 45
minute set you deter at the 32 minute
Mark and talk to somebody while they're
dropping checks I feel it I've done that
sure that's a Mastery to start talking
when they drop in check cuz you ain't
going to get no laughter anyway they
just looking at the Bill H $62 [__] that
[__] this [__] sucks this guy
sucks dick he was good for 20 at the
door but for 64 so now that's the gift
now how can you get them out of their
head how can you get them out of their
head when they get that check and
they're looking at that check that's
what Young Comics never add into the
[__] thing till you're on stage and
you see it happening what was the first
time you saw so it happen check yeah I
can't remember I just know that like any
jokes I was doing weren't really working
and I just stopped cuz I didn't want to
waste anything yeah you don't understand
Le it's like wait until they're done pay
and then you can get back into then you
get then you once they go on that wall
and they drop it and now you get them
now that's the gift picking them back up
again and ending with [__] 29 punches
that's the gift I always hear Headliners
complain about check drops are there no
clubs who like there's a couple have a
couple come on after or maybe pre- buby
the drinks no well there's a couple
people that do check drops after Jim
Norton Jim Norton is definitely yeah
well there's also like uh the Acme Acme
in Minneapolis is a club that that's
like a standard and why why don't more
more clubs do it if everyone hates they
don't want people to run out they lose
customers they feel again again they're
not concerned with the comedian killing
they're concerned with getting paid and
like people can run out a lot easier if
the check drops at the end a lot of
[__]
clubs uh and let's get it a lot of clubs
in the colored
nature bro to be PC I'm PPC up at The
Comedy Store on Tuesday nights the cops
are always there somebody tries to run
out of the tab is that is that black
knight Black Knight you know whatever
they want to call it I didn't want to
say call it they don't call it Black
Knight they D and dash [__]
those black people will D and dash in
2015 15 like they don't give a [__] and
I know in Miami at the Miami Improv
there was a cop always there with dogs
outside just in case nobody [__] ran
out of tab there there's some Club on
those nights that they they have fire
hoses no they give you a they give you a
[__] ticket and that's how you get
out of the club okay they give you a
ticket that you paid the the tab so
that's the only way you get out of the
club so it's different things me do I
prefer it I learned to work around it I
learned to work around it's a way of
business it's part of the business and
after you die 30 times doing it you
figure it out that's when you may go you
know what's going on with you did you
your ass and now you get them boom now
you go into your last 10 minutes of your
set a lot of comics come up with like a
check drop joke check drop joke he says
every night or the thing I just play it
by here these are the things you go
along with
experience that you'll never know like
there's guys that try to fake the funk
like they'll feat you one night and do
38 sets and they go I'm ready to
headline yeah and they'll call a club in
like North Dakota and make up all these
stories and say the newspaper came to
see him and they get a fake [__]
review and they do a paper mche and they
print it on the thing and they send it
and this poor bastard pays him 00 this
kid comes and dies a slow [__] debt
plus the big debt is once the checks
come and he fractures up on stage how
you doing you want another cookie no you
look like you're [__] stumbling and
mumbling over there you [__] I feel
like I'm stumbling and mumbling oh you
know you looking good tonight what's
going on with you how was your weekend
it was a good weekend I had a [__] up
thing happened yesterday but what
happened yesterday now no I was going
through my bank account I found someone
I must have made a mistake and and
thrown away one of those High interest
checks the bank sends you which I've
never ever used so someone sent 730
bucks to the gas company someone went
through your trash and then paid their
gas bill they must of I mean I Joy
thought I was someone who come and clean
clean my house but I haven't had anybody
clean my house those [__] marines
that came over like this [__] it's
been over a month this guy's an acting
and they just did it like days shot
three guys
in but it uh Valentine's day was awesome
what did you eat when I took the mom and
her to In and Out All right we happy
what' you eat just double double with
fries I tried I tried getting them well
done still sucked you don't hold on you
don't like In-N-Out Burger the burgers
are good the fries I don't like they're
they're too thin and they like they have
nothing it's like like there's nothing
in the middle of it it's like just air
you ate them though I ate half of them I
I honestly I don't eat the the in and
how long did you wait till you went and
got the wings like 7 hours and how many
wings did you get I got the small
whatever that has and whatever Buffalo
Wild Wings has I think it's like eight
so this is all Valentine's Day In and
Out in Buffalo Wild Wings because we've
been on a diet since June and we haven't
had anything like that gotta so normally
I'd be going I'd be dropping 200 but L
luckily y'all got to set up the candle
on the floor
lights no we want we we were going to go
see a movie in between all these fast
food things but there was nothing out uh
cuz we we had this plan since like
October so I she had mentioned wanting
to go to LMA so I took her down there
which I thought was going to be a cool
idea but apparently so did every other
boyfriend in Los Angeles which I didn't
realize but it was Saturday too yeah I
didn't realize the museum was that pack
but it was cool it was I don't really
ever go to museums but it was fun you
guys want to go in and out right now
[__] yeah is that is that edible hitting
you it hit him past plural past partile
[__] of course what am I Rob Museum yeah
when does it end with you what's you
you're always talking about knowledge
and I got to see some cool art [__]
Museum Lee when does it end with you
when you what's wrong with the museum
now you know what I'm going to do I'm
going to go home and Google a set of Jew
balls and send them to you used to be a
criminal going to night classes what's
wrong with the museum on a
Saturday my point okay what is Saturday
night I did have dick night on night we
went at like 4 in the afternoon or 3 in
the afternoon I had dick drove downtown
on Valentine all we disc so wasn't it
was like a 20-minute try why you what is
wrong with you lately are you just so
what advice have you been giving him
don't there there's no advice to give
him he's the softest manica every every
night is Dick night it doesn't matter
what she likes there's no Subway what
else nothing of course there's no Ranch
this guy it's amazing how it's just to
me he gets talked into every oh bad
thing's WR with ever heard in my life
the I I I feel bad from like after the
first time you get burnt as a man you
know where your girlfriend's at you pull
a a angle look right I ain't doing that
[__] no if she ever breaks up with you
you're going to be like I took that
[__] to the museum on Saturday
Valentine's Day you don't do none of
that [__] right now I got I got I got
dick morning and Dick night on Sat you
got nothing you got nothing you got
nothing shades you got 50 Shades of I
see that movie you don't lick her ass
hole you didn't come in her cheek on her
face or nothing that's what Valentine's
is about I know you you probably [__]
come in your hand when she's sucking
your dick I come in my hand but I don't
aim at her cheek you don't blow a load
in her mouth nothing you fil I her mouth
no you don't you probably come in the
tissue and you WIP no
butu not during sex I just eat a cookie
where you you [__] embarrass me you
look hungry why you eat a c a cookie
that's a good cookie there's a delicious
cookie but I'm [__] throwing out of
my mind already that's all right we here
I got a package of thin mints at the
house I got one box what type of thin
mints that's all it's just thin minutes
a [__] Museum don't think we forgot
about the [__] what's wrong with the
museum you've never been to a museum not
at 4 in the afternoon a [__] Saturday
what else you want to do what do you
think you do what do you think you do
Lee you can't you're already deal you're
already dealt with [__] terrible [__]
all [__] day from in and out with
Grandma the [__] the [__] Wings
the [__] a cookie how long
how long did you wait at PJs for a seat
no we went at like midnight there was no
one there come on we waited like 20
minutes at Buffalo Wild Wings but there
was a Kings game and a UFC fight so it
was busy listen the guy gave you a
[__] robe B you should have given her
a robe and taken her home and lit the
robe on fire and [__] her till the
robe burnt under the carpet that's what
Valentine's Day just set it on fire say
we're not to the you that chocolate with
the Cherry in it sure you finger her a
little bit get that monkey wet and you
put that cherry in her monkey and lick
that [__] to the chocolate mouth
send her mother home you see I'm saying
and you send Grandma home put her on the
[__] bus you're an embarrassment to
Jews I should rip that [__] flag down
right why there's not one Jew that takes
his [__] girlfriend and Mom to no
[__] in Burger yes he tells her walk
behind me like my wife you ever see on
Beverly Bullard you ever see Jews
walking together no you see the Jew the
man of the house walking straight see
the woman in the back like Rocky and
they have to [__] through a sheet who
gives a [__] but that's all that matters
right or wrong you like that sheet on
fire you like that sheet on fire you
[__] bark
[__] fire you're slipping
[__] bark [__]
so so how long did a mom hang on the
date 20 minutes it was it was lunch we
went to lunch then we went to the gym
okay then you went to the game
gym and then we went to dinner
and uh no when you go to the gym you you
sit on the epileptical next to her no we
never sit next to each other what does
she do she is the elliptical just a
different one she goes [__] fast you
ever see couples jogging together isn't
that the [__] worst Le any day you
see him in the Hollywood Park with his
hoodie but it's worse when guys are next
to each other they're loud at least when
a guy and a girl are next to each other
they kind of I mean like running through
the neighborhood they go jogging
together it's like y'all can't be apart
for a half an hour it's [__]
embarrassing he knows I shoot he knows I
like a vigil him up as he's as he's
walking you don't want to shoot him in
the leg Joy's got people out there
looking at you man he does people he
just Joey's just doing it you call Joey
like he was on Wilshire today you just
have like little rotations for all your
friends you look surveillance man I go
out I leave the house early man yeah
[__] yeah I got to out the house I see
on whenever I'm up early I see your ass
up early as [__] you guys used to do
this podcast at 6 a.m. [__] morning
for a year do that anymore you know it
was rough it was fun but like it those
people who do that [__] no if Lee came
to me if a station came to us and said
we want you to do morning radio
somewhere that's morning radio that
means you're paying me enough that there
ain't no comedy Monday through Friday
right you follow me if you come to me
and say I want you to do more on the
radio well this is what I do on a
Thursday this what I do on a Friday you
got to cover that yeah if that's the r
or we shoot two which isn't going to
work right morning radio is morning
radio you got to do it you got to talk
about the topics of the morning and the
that's what they need to do so I would
do it but to do 4 days a week when you
got to get up at 3:30 damn you got to be
in bed at 700 and if you have a live
remote that throws your whole [__]
schedule off if you you know you got you
got to go to bed at 700 every night so
your [__] machine working all time
right 4 hours 7 and a half hours and get
up at 3:30 that's at the studi around
the [__] Corner what if you're half
hour away you got to drink coffee smoke
cigarettes get some reefer you a couple
Stars you got to go to bed at 400 p.m.
p.m. every goddamn day I know people
would do it I know people would do it
yeah yeah I had an aunt who worked for
the IRS who would go at like 3: 4:00
a.m. or something cuz you got out by 3:
or really early so she could be home for
her
kids a lot of people do it 4:00 a.m.
Jesus Christ yeah yeah and I can see it
doing it here you think about doing it
here it's easy Cy right do that [__] in
Boston now where you got to go outside
and [__] blow torch your windshield
yeah I called my mom today she said
there's people who just don't have their
cars because plows have just been going
by and packing them in they just there's
a parking band but they literally even
if they wanted to get to their car it's
behind like 20 ft of snow right now [__]
how many inches I over my mom in Wester
has over
100 and it's not even the most like 96
had like 11 11 it's going to come again
on Friday it's coming again tomorrow for
like 3 Ines oh my God that's [__] man
and I lived through those Winters 20 30
years ago go on the East Coast I lived
through one of those where he just kept
[__] snowing yeah it's like every day
and I I have a Facebook friend or who
who I went to high school with him and
he went to jail a couple times and I
keep seeing pictures he has like a a
station wagon with a long fence tied
bungee cordage to the top of it and he's
just going and him and his brother put
up a job posting they were paying each
guy 200 a day to help them because they
just had so much work so like a lot of
people are working right now cuz sure
they're
sh do yeah there's work to be done Hey
listen when I lived in snow MK and I
first moved up there I used to shovel
snow me to for 12 an hour 12 an hour
Jack and I'd be casing Apartments cuz it
was the apartment billing they' be doing
me a favor I just be seeing when the
drug dealers were coming and
going my boss's name was Joe coffee the
apartment building was Creekside
remember that time you wrote a check to
the gas company from a check you stole
you son of a no no $700 oh [__] I would
that that's I wasn't a check guy I was
never a check guy being a check guy or
like a a car car thief you're in there
they got you yeah they got there's no
turning back yeah especially now with
the cameras yeah especially now with the
cam now it must be brutal you can't do a
credit card no more with a [__]
camera that was that was my bread and
butter with credit cards you know find
the [__] credit tonight I was looking
at for cards I was looking for a
business card I had a stack of them and
I put him in one of those clips and when
I was looking through him I remember
this guy I had I lived in a
building in 85 for about a month yeah a
friend of mine said listen you could you
could crash
here so the super of the building was
across the hall this is the weirdest
thing and this in [__] Jersey the
super of the building was across the
hall but when you it said come in when
you open the door the keys to all the
apartments were on the wall and then you
rang his
doorbell what the [__] kind and it would
take him three 4 minutes hey what do you
want right there's no water tonight turn
it back on you know whatever I would and
one night one afternoon I I got I didn't
have a job for a week and I got [__]
bored and I said what the [__] is going
on around and I took the key to it was
like the three floor house and there was
a chick that had gigantic tits on the
third floor like the Bunny Ranch I used
to snort coke and jerk off to her she
had like a [__] up boyfriend she was
hotter than [__] yeah and one day I went
upstairs and opened up her apartment I
went in the boyfriend had a big desk and
I opened up the desk and it had a a a
stack of credit cards mhm with that with
the clip in it like Diner club and all
every gasoline company this is 19
[__]
85 and I would take like uh his American
Express and i' go to like Chinatown
spend 200 and come home and put it
back and jerk up on them titties all
over I would do that I got his hourly
you know I know him and her were home
and I would go up knock on the door open
up go into his office take a card use it
for the afternoon bring it back and put
in the [__] thing I did that for
about maybe two weeks yeah and then one
day I said what am I even putting them
back for what am I wasting my time I'm
going into this guy's apartment every
day like a [__] [__] I just started
taking them and I just started r that
but now since I was doing that clip
today I got a flashback of I'm like
thank God I don't have 30 credit cards
somebody think they're in the [__]
this card clip and take them all it's
[__] up did you ever feel bad about
that one about like stuff like that I
just remembered that late tonight that
was the first time I thought of that in
30 years that was 1985 sure I felt bad
sure I felt bad but but you didn't pay
for it it wasn't like you pay pay for it
out of your well they said they have to
do like an a an investigation
investigation I felt like I thought they
were like accusing me of writing a bad
check to the gas company or I they are
they are they're going to get you
they're going to come over be and throw
you in jail for an afternoon that's why
you got to eat cookies straight through
it eat this cookie eat another piece of
cookie it's way I thought you talking
about like good cookies I talking
about little piece I'm good I'm good I
got some in my pocket if I need it oh
[__] I'm peer pressure in Lee but I'm a
lightweight come on you taking another
piece we're going deep tonight I loved
it but I can't I'm going to die we got
about four nights to go out
I'm we got about a big week this week
Big Show at the ice house Wednesday
night really yeah for us oh wait no no
you're doing Roan show yeah we're going
to have a good time you're not going to
stay at home no I'll come all right
don't we have a podcast ones day who
knows I don't know what's with the
questions I'm talking about night time
what's the Poss oh
[__] look at you [__] ding of things
all the
time that's a good I want to be around
and no really cuz most stuff with weed
in it tastes terrible that's a good
cookie somebody breaks your heart can
you teach me how to do the bark thing
yeah you got to cover your mouth you got
to cover your mouth and it's got to be
from like the back of your throat you
got to put a lot of air through
there that's F another piece of cookie
and then we'll teach you how to do the
bark all right it takes practice you
can't just jump in you can't just get it
for a try you have a lot of experience
your girl oy spooky was there looking
good miss your boy Daniel was there he
gave me the [__] Andrew Daniel D
Daniel was dead I'm high as [__] I
remember that Andrew [__] Miller my
boy from [__] Dallas showed up with
Cuban pastries again oh Dave Wilder no
no oh he came last time yeah he's a good
dude man I gotta send him a little
[__] Camp package he's a good dude
yall know a guy named Uki
spooky very cute she yeah she showed up
a lot of PE it's it's nice not going on
you have this relationship with some
Twitter people you see him and you know
how Ryan kassos came out me and him been
playing uh you know [__] uh whatever
the [__] email tag for a year on Gmail I
need to go see ooie spooky cuz like her
pictures like the picture that [__] me
up and made me go on a diet like that
picture I have with her where my head
looks like it was like blown up from the
inside you swalling like me you're
swollen you're not swolling no more
you're looking good let me see the crab
give me a little crab pose look at you
you're [__] B let me see a front
double bicep blast this what you were
doing what you were doing no the other
one up there you go look at you you're a
[__] you're beautiful man you're a
[__] soash you started in
Baltimore I didn't start doing stand up
there but I I spent some time there
where did you start la like a fool and
then you went back to Baltimore and you
fell in love no no no no I I grew up in
southern Maryland In The Sticks went to
college in Baltimore moved to LA started
open mics in the valley in 98 and just
[__] work my way up man and then you
went back to Baltimore never went back
to Baltimore then what the [__] you
saying when you you did comedy in
Baltimore I never did comedy in
Baltimore did you say that today I
thought he said some I live in Baltimore
who the [__] knows I've done it out
there but I never went you started
comedy here yeah yeah just like [__]
tripley and seura and these other fools
we started out here actually tripley
didn't start out here no he started in
Vegas seora did did he or in
Columbus uh as far as I know he started
out here I think he started out here
from the podcast I didn't know that I
wasn't [__] sure at all hey man
it's a tough racket to start out here
for me but once you get over that hump
it's okay the good thing is there's a
lot of open mics out here and you you're
way more off the radar than people say
you are if you just do open mics in the
valley [__] bud Freeman ain't seeing
your ass nobody you know no one's seeing
your ass now who do you remember from 90
and anybody around back then that's
still around now when I started when I
first first started like the first open
mics I did tripley had just moved to
town so he was doing all the open mics
too
um uh Kira
salanovic was around she used to always
be a he was a [__] Hustler that's one
thing you can't take from her that girl
was out yeah I saw her every [__]
night with a notebook in her hand I used
to sit there and go this [__] girl I
love it when I see a woman work that
hard I [__] love it cuz most of them
you know they want to sell their tits
and right have a boyfriend right for
them or whatever the [__] they do some
girls like I'm not playing that [__]
[__] homie I'm going [__] straight
Homie don't play that [__] [__] I'm
doing my own game while I'm talking
about women I'm not want to shot send a
birthday shout out to Sarah Tiana yeah I
couldn't uh get a babysit I forgot Mar
what's her name the babysit left at 3
today so uh we couldn't go down to a
party over at uh where's the Party
Busters oh no [__] from 4: to 8 [__]
wait it's a daytime party I get [__] for
going to Museum and you were going to go
to mdav Busters with my child with a
[__] Youngy old child and my wife D
Busters is like for for a Comics
birthday who did the podcast and is very
cool because somebody said I want to go
to the museum for Valentine you said
okay and you went down there like a
[__] half a homo you know look at all
the other guys that were there see if
any other [__] guy wanted to be there
in your heart you could look at me as a
man and say you really wanted to be in a
[__] Museum on a sat at 4:00 all
shoulder to shoulder looking at
paintings you know fun though
it was fun though so was getting shot in
the [__] [__] that's fun too you
know what was really fun was parking at
the Museum on Saturday this guy get
talked into the worst things ever that
I've ever seen ever ever ever ever in my
life the in oute at the point he's in
his oh yeah that sounds great sounds
good you know that sounds all that
shit's easy it's the other [__] he gets
involved in look I'm sorry [__] sorry
you know I love you to death I don't
give a [__] you going to regret this
[__] 3 years from now you're going to
see why he he doesn't know he doesn't
know he thinks that what we're telling
him is like right you know we're just
telling you this because if you don't
Gras a hold of this now 5 years from now
to grow away weed and by that time when
she tells you to go [__] yourself don't
come crying to me don't come in
here because you're the guy that wants
to do everything she wants to do and
eventually a woman says I'm looking for
a [__] man I'm not looking for a
[__] hologram that's to wipe my feet
that's in a fairy tale women want to
know their [__] place Lisi so always
remember that she's going to meet a
[__] attorney that's a man and she
going to go this guy cuz he he has a
[__] voice you have to have a voice
as a [__] man every once in a while
and go you know what valtine I'm not
going down there I don't need to go to
no Museum to see all what am I Da Vinci
I'm leis Sayad radio personality yeah
you you want to go get a [__] uh you
want to go to Radio Shack and get a
[__] VCR I'm in now practice saying
that I'm Le
radio personality so what's going to H
this is what happens make your muscles
when you do it what do you think to H
half of couples what do you think
happens to couples well go I don't want
to because you didn't establish yourself
in the beginning go I'm not doing that
on a Thursday though you do that here 20
bucks you like the bus hop along let me
give you the wp let me give you the wrap
down there you like the bus sure and I
see us all the time I saw I'm going
through this with Franchesca the
austino's sister women love that [__] in
the beginning for about a year and a
half then one day they wake up and they
go I got a mop over here I tell this
[__] mop what to do right and he does
it like a [__] slave it's not too
late to shift gears no so now you have a
problem now you're going to go I don't
want to do that she's going to say well
you've changed you got to fight through
that now you got to fight through that
so if you tell them who the [__] you are
from day one you never have a problem
listen I want to go to your Museum like
I want 10 [__] black guys [__] me
in the ass all right let's be honest
same level for you same level now repeat
after
me in 3 years when you have a childh
that's different that's a museum you get
the Hat you go see electronics and
Pirates but with a grown [__] woman a
24 year old woman there's only one thing
to do on a Saturday afternoon and it
ain't the tarpit yeah it's dick
afternoon dick afternoon on Valentine's
what' you get that studio apartment for
to sit there by yourself no to give a
dick dick morning if not you should live
in the tent we we had dick morning and
then dick night no you I know you yeah I
did well you had vagina Museum vagina
afternoon yeah but you have vagina
afternoon you got to get it together
there more dicks than vaginas sure
you're a [__] Legend if not she going
to go what am I dating this guy for I
might as well just get a butler to rub
my feet do what the [__] I want to
do letting them know their place is a
very harsh way of saying it let yeah let
everybody know their [__] place in
life you know that what the [__] you
think it just starts at home you tell
everybody I didn't tell my wife she was
a Peasley slave I explain you know I
told her she I didn't want show I didn't
want her com to comedy shows with me yes
that's a big I had to tell them from the
beginning because I made a mistake with
another girlfriend I finally I finally
you follow me so all we're trying to
tell you is what to do now because
that's a good idea I'll try it you have
to try Lee but the problem is I don't
mind doing a lot of this stuff because
you're half a fact that's right because
you might as well put Wings on you want
to go for tell me the TRU you want to
really go make macaroons this is what
Macar know when you were in college you
shot there one day and you said you know
what cooking class was fun it did steak
okay well how many steaks have you
cooked since that it was like two weeks
ago yeah all right nothing all right
what about the other one what'd you go
for crepes that was fun yeah that was
fun how many Crepes have you cooked
since the class like one nothing you
haven't cooked the [__] thing how
many Crepes has she [__] cooked none
none then what you go to the [__]
class for so at least you have that in
your back pocket how many macaroons did
she [__] make since then how many
steaks has she cooked in then none then
what's the class for for fun no [__] you
want fun get a hat with a propeller and
get a water pistol sprinkling her
[__] that's fun run around the house
that's [__] fun a cooking class is so
you got this now right right we don't
ever have to go to Ruth Chris only for
your birthday now you're going to make
steaks twice a week yeah let me teach
you how to make two eggs you can throw
together two eggs in a steak for
breakfast and let me teach you how to
use the toaster for some toast that's
why you go to [__] cooking class so
after dick morning you get some no
that's why I go to cooking class I can't
cook I'm horrible right the other day I
made a cheese onet for breakfast cuz
they weren't up and they both came out
while I was cooking it and my my
daughter looked at me cooking and she
looked at my my wife she's like you
still going to cook breakfast right Dad
is cool as [__] but look at that [__]
disaster yeah I need to take a [__]
cooking class that's why you Tak cooking
class to learn how to cook right right
my lion here maybe I'm [__] delusion
no that is how many Mac how many
macaroons do you have to eat though how
many did you [__] make since that
class none you don't make macaroons so
this week you got to tell her listen
when you come over Friday let's whip up
those macaroons you were supposed to
[__] take notes on in class all right
PS I hate
museums I used to hate museums take a
cookie will you a cookie for your for
your sins this weekend take a little
piece it's only 5 milligram Body of
Christ that's a lie you go it's only 5
Mill the whole cookie [__] 22
milligrams yeah right they would never
make a random number no I'm okay it's
only like uh 3 milligrams I'm looking at
it on my my computer right here I'm over
here for you I love you cop [__] I
thought you were I thought you were like
mad at me last night or something cuz I
called you and you were like really
quiet on the phone and he told me you
ate like some saltwater taffy that just
s over the moon oh oh yeah that was
[__] up last night I passed out people
bring you treats in uh in Austin or you
brought your own me a treat here oh cool
okay some little [__] Taffy that was
[__] strong as [__] I couldn't watch
the TV no more I had to keep blinking
and stuff he was like there was
something wrong with my [__] eyeballs
you've been going out a lot in the road
my brother this year yeah January I went
out a bunch of places where'd you go I
headlined in North Carolina Wilmington
North Carolina there's this place called
the dead crow comedy club which is off
the hook I did some indie shows in
Florida and I opened for my boy Ian bag
in Kansas City I did The Improv yeah
yeah how's that improv in Kansas City
it's pretty good man it's pretty good it
looks like all the other improvs but
it's pretty fun the audiences are pretty
good they laugh good time I never even
thought of going to can like they
they've never even made an off for
nothing there the other club the guy has
the wig with Josh Wolf goes who you
texting somebody my phone's in my pocket
I hope
so eat a cookie how about are you
texting your girlfriend I'm about to
rock candy are you texting your
girlfriend got to eat something before
you leave this is the sou I already ate
two things that's okay we got we got 10
things so you got to eat three out of 10
what else would you like today let me
see what the options are all right let
me show you no he gets mad when I text
my girlfriend too he doesn't understand
texting conversations right here we got
more cookies wow you can eat a whole
cookie why you want to eat in pieces
this is like the marijuana Olympics got
we got got another star you want to eat
another half star getting a gold want to
eat another half a star was it like this
when you guys used to wake up at 6:00
a.m. was all these treat there were
edibles but not to this level how about
just cereal bar how about a whole cereal
bar what's a bar can I have a a one of
the kernels or is it a bar you getting
too thinly snack on some of [__] not
when I eat that Munchies I could I went
to I I went to yum yums at 11:00 p.m.
the other I bought one of these just eat
one of these nice rock candy is a 10 oh
wait no is it a chewy one or a hard one
these a hard can I have a chewy one I
don't have a [__] chewy candy you got
some you got the cereal things the only
thing we don't got is chewy no no
there's no more chewy try a rock cand
it's good for you it's got vitamin D in
it but it's going to sound bad on the
microphone don't a you don't have to say
nothing just sit there look at the stars
twet I get would disagree with you look
at the stars of David you looking Le you
looking good look at your
eyeballs do they match my shirt what
flavor you want red or blue is good
there's a nice red one for you we've had
these before yeah they're delici they
don't do nothing yes they do they don't
do
nothing can you drive me home ain't
nobody driving you home ain't nobody
driving nobody home oh [__] we got this
[__] big a brownie oh you're going to
want that brownie have you tried this
brownie you want this oh [__] sure yeah
a go see that's how we do it we don't
[__] around this better than in and out
we open it what are you going to take he
I got it to go you want to bite now I
got a cookie right here oh you want this
brownie now while you're chewing on a
hard candy all right we'll open the
brownie what the [__] man look at you
nibble on the cookie oh yeah look at you
like a mouse I take it slow oh I like it
I call it crumb you know how some people
smoke rocks I eat crumb that's how I do
it I know I'm disappointing you but
that's how I do it you're EA you're
headlining some that's how you do please
bro at l in San Diego this year you know
little no it's this joint called
uh Tipsy Crow I think I played the dead
crow and the Tipsy Crow this year
already I'm a crow comic Crow comic then
there's a crow up in uh up in uh not San
Jose but the what's the hip Community up
there
Francisco Santa Cruz Santa Cruz they
have old running how's the candy stuck
on my teeth but it's good did oh thank
yeah oh my God Le Lee you're going super
deep you you want to call Brownie you
want to call the ambulance right now do
you have one on sampai I call I thought
you said never to sign for an ambulance
it's 911 sign for an ambulance we're not
going to sign you on I got an ID that's
fake you just [__] get your oxygen
and get out of there run out of there
and they'll never see you again would
oxygen help well we're going to do a
couple things
here so just call 911 oh my God when
they come tell them we're just kidding
or maybe you'll need it who knows red B
get really [__] up and call an
ambulance $1,500 later oh your heart's
going to beat don't call the cops start
breathing just breathe your way out of
it that's it through your nose out your
mouth you got this and breathe and when
you get enough energy go get some coffee
not coffee some tea I [__] hate tea
what do you hate tea you hate coffee
yeah well I don't hate C I just never
tried to like it cuz it's too expensive
coffee is too expensive what are you
talking about [__] people in like in
Boston go like yeah these [__]
jerk you're the King of Swing I am the
king of SW all right you get yourself a
little [__] thing with a little
coffee a little Starbucks I got a CG
yeah then what the [__] you want home
where' you get the CG from Amazon for
how much like 80 bucks you don't drink
coffee Paula does but if I didn't get it
we were going to go go to breakfast
every day so now we make breakfast
breakfast at the Museum you were going
to the museum do you break you know what
they got some good pastries over there
no no but no we eat breakfast we tried
to go to Denny's over the weekend and it
was just terrible how bad was it just
the manager there was like the worst
like she was for some reason helping the
host where anyone who's worked in a
restaurant knows you help run food like
let the host like the they were running
on three different things of paper so
Paul and I got skipped over for like
three tables did you tell them your Le s
radio personality I should have you
should have told them so what did you
end up doing you went home no we waited
we were there a [__] hour for eggs no
I tell you one I told you on the phone
we were already there by that [__]
thinking didn't I tell you that when you
were there didn't I say what are you
doing there yeah it's only going to be
quick they said 5 to 10 minutes listen
after 9:00 you don't go to breakfast
right you're [__] in this town you
cash in on that cooking class they leave
in church so you have a 20 minute wait
especially if you go with somebody if
you go alone you could always grab the
[__] bar you follow me the
counter baby the counter but you got to
you know what I'm saying you got to make
a date with you so after 9:30 once that
first MK empties
out you're in no danger that's Sunday
101 do you know what was my favorite
when she lived in Englewood I'd Dr go
drop her off at night for like dinner
and go to dinner the people at Chili's
and Red Lobster were in their Sunday
Best like purple suits yeah and it was
full of them black people love Red
Lobster you heard here first folks if
you want to sleep with a black woman
from the [__] Hood yeah throw up Red
Lobster they go [__] and all they say
to you is like you going to take me the
Red Lobster you going to get me one of
them drinks it's not red lob it's those
purple drinks at six [__] dollars a
piece that drives them [__] nuts
drives black women crazy it's like smok
and crack they go from crack hose to Red
Lobster [__] hose oh yeah yeah down
there where what's the other place
Chili's oh yeah that's big time they go
in there smoking cigarett and people
like say like we going to ch and other
people are jealous
oo
yeah it's like Museum to a black person
[__] yeah I love it I love going to
[__] Red Lobster in Sacramento tons
of black people hysterical they don't
give a [__] they will suck the red off
the crab leg like once they don't only
[__] take the meat out of it yeah
they suck the red right out of the f I
love it I love it they don't give a [__]
if they got to pay $9 for that crab leg
they get every nutrient out of
[__] that's in there they got uh
Magic Johnson tji Fridays have you seen
those no but they used to have Magic
Johnson movie theaters in La they don't
have no no no I went to one when I
interned out here I think it was like in
a bad area probably since it was yes it
was a bad that's what I'm saying but I
went there like when I was before I even
moved out here to work when I was out
here interning the summer before and
they don't have that
anymore there was a shopping center by
the airport it's got like uh Magic
Johnson tji Fridays and like black
Starbucks it was so great I met darl
right there one day
and it was uh I was like I'm sitting at
such and such a table and he's like oh I
think I'm going to be able to pick you
out cuz I was the only white guy there
but it was funny dude it was like they
were listen to the regular Starbucks
shitty Coffee House Music it was just
like a regular white Starbucks but it
was black Starbuck it was beautiful
there was guy rolling around playing
Pink Floyd in the parking lot black dude
it was like alternate universe it was
fantastic it's kind of cool in like
Korea Town where they have like Korean
ads like you just be rolling around La
and then all of a sudden all the ads are
Korean Western yeah down Western just
it's horrible as opposed to Spanish
everywhere else no when you yeah when
you go down West and it's like Mexican
music that just becomes Korean and all
the Koreans stop they don't know like
the double Park they just stop you're
just sitting there for five minutes
you're like why is that traffic and you
get in the left hand lane it's wide
[__] open they just stoping talking
to each other they don't give a [__] I
got caught down there one time for an
hour I'll never dve down Weston I think
I'm Western and Melrose I [__] Tap
Out Jack that's is teral yeah no there's
no [__] use it's it's the uh when I
went to Austin that was the biggest
complaint from people and how much
Austin had grown and how bad the traffic
was and I tried to explain to the 30
people that said that to me I go you
know what there's traffic everywhere and
mindboggling traffic [__]
mindboggling traffic some days you you
can't wrap your head around when I come
up Laurel Canyon at 3:00 it be who's
melee and how slow people are going and
it's a [__] hour yeah it's 45 minutes
sometimes to get a [__] low Canyon
that's not even that much I can't tell
you how many times I spent two hours on
the 405 from Santa Monica to Sherman
Oaks an hour and a half not not a
problem Wednesday nights because the
longest part of it is getting to the
freeway which I don't think other cities
have but that's 6:00 [__] having a job
and not getting home till 7:15 with
that's it there's no accidents and no
jerk offs Dad I can't do that no it's
horrible I used to have a job on the
West Side lived on the east side and
every morning it was just like suicide
watch I mean I try my best this is
before I had [__] GPS or [__] I would
just take the tent and just like with a
gun in my mouth oh no you got on the oh
yeah well I take Olympics sometimes I
take this that and the other Wilshire
but it sucked either way and when you
first move here the streets are super
[__] long so you think oh I'm this is
the Olympic right here my job's on
Olympic I'll just go and it's 3 days
later you're at work I know it's
terrible I made appointments to go down
there today because there was no traffic
it was I left my house at 9:30 be on
Wilshire at 10:00 I got there 5: to
[__]
10: but I I can't do it no more I can't
go over the hill I love going to heagan
and stuff in the daytime I love training
with day but I'm just waiting for what's
his name to open up his school up over
the hill so I can zip in at lunch and
get the [__] out of there by
1:00 that one hour on the way down to 45
on the way back that two at 10:00 I got
to leave to be there at 10: to [__]
11: yeah man and the traffic gets heavy
every time I I'm going up to Hill there
days I don't think I'm going to [__]
make it at all man I'm like I'm not
going to make it to [__] jju today
it's just too much and and that's the
way it is everywhere New York City is
the same [__] way when I go to Dallas
there's tons of traffic forget [__]
Miami DC Baltimore DC you know we're
just I don't know if I you know I could
sit here and say it's overcrowded or we
have too many cars because everybody's
on the [__] train too yeah you're on
a [__] train at 9:00 you got some guy
breathing down your [__] neck and a
Japanese guy with a surgeon's mask on
you know so don't tell me that the
trains are [__] empty you know no
they're packed you think no one takes
the train in La they're [__] packed
packed mass transit is packed in La
those they don't have one to the West
Side that's just the fact that they
don't have one from the 405 down to the
10 they're working on stupid [__] it's
going to take decades but they're
working on it cuz they know know La is
[__] as far as traffic is concerned
and yeah they they uh they do already
have one that goes to Long Beach oh they
do have they already have it my
girlfriend are joking but do you ever
think like there should be like some
sort of time limit on being here if
you're not doing something in your fi if
you don't knock it out of the park after
20 years if successful or anything it's
just there's so many people here who are
just like my [__] Danny's waiter was
from Boston and was B like one step away
from doing Goodwill hunting scenes at my
table uh-huh it was just embarrassing to
watch was he doing he was just joking
around with about boxing and cheers and
he was he was just being really like he
was being overly hammy and it was like
the first time I'd seen it and then
Paula takes lifts home sometimes from
the train station and she said like
every other one is like an actor who
like hands her a script or it's just
it's I get that it's tough but at some
point we need more
space there should be a talent like a
talent measurement
of California or at LAX where you have
to do a monologue she like a Visa and to
like show like hey I'm working or just
let the people who are born here stay
here and do that kind of work you know
but then you read these stories that
people here 11 years they finally apart
thing that's the thing and we know it
takes long a dream is a dream is a dream
you can be working towards it you don't
have to be a star but like you can't
just be like going to parties in
Hollywood listen not everybody's least
at radio personality you know what I
mean you can't judge these people you
know you asked me when I was the most
frustrated in my comedy career the most
frustrated was in
'95 when I wanted just to feature and
work I wanted just to get comedy work
and I was working around Denver and
getting guess sets when you're prepared
when people come up to you and saying
you're ready to do you get frustrated
you know and the other frustration I got
was here there was one point where I was
uh but I was frustrated at the fouryear
mark That's when I I really got
frustrated I you know frustration is
when nothing's going on that's when you
feel bad about yourself so that's when
the frustration comes in what if I mean
you know I'm really lucky and I'm really
aggressive and I'm I'm a hustler and
sometimes ignorance is bliss absolutely
because when I walked into Bronx County
I knew nothing about acting nothing I
had just signed with an agency called
the coloring book that's how bad this
agency was people right and I get a call
one day that they want to see me at
Bronx County at CBS on Fifth Street in
Santa Monica and I go down there to play
a Puerto Rican bartender in a [__]
bar which I hate all those roles cuz I
can never pull them off right but the
cast director was so [__] great that
he pulled it out of me and I don't know
how with no acting experience no acting
classes I booked the CBS pilot and they
paid me money and and you know it was
great and I shot the [__] pilot
for seven months I lived confused I
didn't know if I should buy a house
right tell [__] to shut the [__] up
you know you're going to do that yeah
you know and also we go to the museum
Joey and also the pilot didn't get
picked up what is that what is that dude
to the normal person that hasn't taken
an acting class he's like I'm better
than these guys or whatever I don't know
what I was [__] thinking on my mind
then I went in for basetball and that's
how I got my S card because that was the
second book I got basetball then I got a
Taco Bell commercial you know like and
at that point I was doing comedy maybe
seven years so was it the states time
that gave me the the uh PTO to go in
there the balls I don't know I used to
just work myself up be so scared I go in
there and blow up in the [__] room
you know but Lee what kept me here what
what kept me here what made me go to
Houston and go you know what I can't
believe Adam sand has want me to
audition for his movie you know what I'm
going to make an audition tape what if I
was the regular Schmo and didn't think
that way I didn't take no for an answer
I didn't give a [__] you're either going
to go with big [__] at Tony serus and
they're great as celebrities but this is
a comedy if you want this movie to work
I've done Buffalo at halftime I have to
send my tape in and I sent it in and we
got the [__] movie but there's a lot
of people that go through this town and
don't do anything for 15 and you see
them and you feel [__] bad right and
there's some people who get it I told
the story about last year I went to The
Grudge Match Premiere and I came out and
I saw a kid I was with 15 years ago
we're both on the same path in com and
now he was working at a $10 store on
Hollywood Boulevard and how bad I felt
talking to him and how negative he was
about the town right and it killed me it
killed me for about a week I talked on
the podcast and about a month ago I
asked him about they go you didn't hear
he changed his life he quit that job he
quit comedy yeah because he knew that's
it you know he was dressing up as a
[__] bunny suit right at a at a show
once a month that's not comedy you know
and I got got it when he got here book
some commercials but you know this town
has changed 10 years ago a Schmo like me
could come here and book a bunch of [__]
today you're not going to book much cuz
there ain't much to book there ain't
much to book all those co-stars how you
learn how to act those little rows that
you walking and say get up you're under
arrest and people like oh my God you
know people here say go [__] yourself
you two lines people at home like do I'm
proud of you he's a movie star that was
you you're a movie star so that that's
the reality of it rolls are gone that's
how you learn to act and why is that cuz
there's not as many uh TV shows they're
not shooting them here they're hiring
off reals now you know so people don't
even know you exist 10 years ago I would
going to an audition and do okay and let
him go you know what you're not right
for this I'm going keep M ey you it's a
smaller scene right no it was more
action there was more going on okay and
the same people were here but well all
these states have uh tax refund tax
refund so that takes from us you they're
going to shoot the movie there so what
do they do they hire the principles here
but they hire local actors because what
do fly everybody out not going to fly
everybody out put them in a [__]
fourstar hotel and feed them they can
hire actors that are in that area
so that's how they do it which works hey
it [__] works I'm not mad at you so
all those little rows we used to get
here when I handed James Cobrin a gun an
american gun and walked away when I
handed James Cobrin a clipped the sign I
said here I I delivered a box to you I'm
just like you half Italian half Irish
and I walked away all those stupid
[__] roles that you learn to know
about you learn about the extras what
they're doing you learn how to take from
a director you learn how to [__]
stand correctly how to open up in front
of the camera how to walk those are the
roles that you learn those things cuz
you have to do them you're not sitting
there for an hour talking to somebody so
what do you think I think we should
arrest them no [__] no you're just
walking and going hey pick up line four
and you walk out right you know there
was a movie there with transpart and ter
I just grabbed the guy out of a trunk
and said you're going to die and I threw
him in the water and that was it that
was it it took 8 hours to shoot while I
was doing it I was happy as a pig of
[__] yeah if you call me for that road
today I tell go [__] yourself right but
when I got here in 2001 and there I am
on the set with Dayton C from Sons of
Hani and [__] Riser and all these
[__] guys Paul Riser was mean to me
in the makeup chair nice and chance pom
and Terry and all these [__] guys and
there I am going pulling the guy out of
a trunk and going you're going to die
and the guy we pulled out was a stum man
and I saw him at a weed store about two
years ago and he's like remember me how
many times you throw me into that lot we
threw into the Long Beach [__] dock
over there like 18 times one night you
know this is how you learn to act so if
you what do you think you learn to act
by going to some acting school and
giving them
$10,000 that's [__] candy cane [__]
oh I did a scene from from uh Flash
Dance it was the get the [__] out of
here get the [__] out of here seen from
Last Dance [__] you know so that's the
confusion Le I I get the dream I get
what you say I see kids today that'll
come up to me and go hey man it was
really good that Rogan helped you out
well I didn't book movies on my own
right what when you were [__] going
to the movies with your girlfriend I
wasn't at The Comedy Store following
Paul money at 12:30 a [__] night
that's what a lot of people tell that's
what a lot of people don't get you got
to put in work every day yeah they don't
get that you can't just uh work at
Denny's and like hope someone calls you
for an audition and then work like that
[__] working out for me well you got
to hustle you got to take an acting
class and meet other [__] actors and
see what the [__] they're doing and go
hang out where they hang out where they
one ss I go to the actor studio and we
CH then you go to the [__] actor
Studio you chitchat you know all my
parents are coming to time that's not my
problem you should have [__] invited
them yeah you're here working this is
work this [__] work what ain't no
[__] parent ain't nobody unless until
you get the yacht with 10 [__] sucking
your dick right then your parents come
out to visit and your
friends I want to come out for 4 days
for what the [__] live on the Yacht
for what I'm going Entertainer I'm going
to drive you around La and the [__]
10 [__] you you're on your own then they
get here oh yeah we got a hotel room
Marina d looks like I won't see you cuz
I live in North Hollywood [__] that's a
long way you for a long way from home Dy
you know no and that's the problem that
you have people don't understand yeah
that's the people don't understand where
you got going on you start if no one's
hiring you you start working you start
working even if you're not getting paid
you start doing a podcast you start
hitting the stage you start doing the
[__] plays or whatever you start
doing you start making your own movies
that's how you [__] do it talk to Lee
for 5 seconds let me blow my nose real
quick all right it is kind of [__] up
cuz I was I asked you when you came in
how many podcast episodes you have you
like oh [__] [__] that's that's the full
charge Power Hour by the way uh you got
like number 107 right 108 I've done 108
yeah and it's just cool cuz like over
the past year I did a bunch and I'm not
doing some manymore
and it's not even these but just you see
these people start podcasts yeah and I
think they've
seen so many people make some money that
they're expecting Coca-Cola to come
sponsor them in 3 weeks yeah and when it
doesn't happen they just end or or no
you have to build forever you have to
build until it goes you have to keep
putting the work in you know and it
catches when it catches that's the deal
yeah it's and and then they think oh
they're just going to they're just going
to find your like Coca-Cola is going to
have a guy finding your number like they
won't call any sponsors or it's just
it's really weird yeah well most people
don't put the [__] work in what are
you going to do you have to put the work
in every day yeah every goddamn day it's
annoying you want some more pot not
really put your
[__] Dam it got to be a burglar to go
to the bathroom in this [__] place
got to be a [__] burglar what if you
[__] in your [__] pants and I don't
have my ke Keys a [__] burglar
unbelievable how much that pisses me off
a [__] lock on the bathroom like
somebody's going to rob the [__]
toilet paper or some [__] yeah like
homeless people are in and out of this
[__] you know maybe some homeless people
come in so what let them take a [__]
little Puerto Rican show it's better
than on the [__] sidewalk right
listen man it's uh Hey plug this in for
me I think I popped out the wires yeah
there you go youed it up this [__]
why went Kuts and [__] tonight yeah you
know when you have a dream man
I can't tell you I would never go up to
Tom and tell them it's time for them to
leave I have no problem going up to them
and telling them it's time to tighten
their game up exactly there's little
things you do to tighten your game up
what do you do in the afternoon well I
sit with three of my friends I got to
ask you something where are those
[__] two jerk offs going right
nowhere why you sitting with them you
going to sit with somebody go sit with
Dane Cook exactly go sit with [__]
Matt Fon yeah I don't care if you got to
get them coffee care you got to buy them
coffee yeah i' rather ride a joke with
Matt fullron and ride a joke with three
jerk with a [__] mind dream they
elevate you there's so many different
[__] shortcuts how do you prove
yourself you go out six nights a week
when I go out and I see you there and
you you've already done three sets and
you're 22 and I'm at the store 11 you're
like let's do it dog I'm here to hang
out with you to you know I know these
people are real that's people know when
somebody's real I know when somebody
comes me La is not working for me well
how many nights a week do you go out
well nobody puts me up that's not my
[__] question exactly my question is
how many nights a week you want to go up
because I know [__] that get up
three times a night in the [__]
Valley Pasadena hamburger hamlets these
[__] go out you know six nights
a [__] week and if you don't have the
spot go to the [__] show anyways and
get to know the [__] that run
it next everybody wants to do the Improv
destroying the life fact and if they
don't get into those three they get
caught up and it affects them where me
I'm working on the spot don't worry
about that that'll be there that's not
going anywhere that's always going to
[__] be there what I want you to do
is just keep getting on stage yeah but
my friend [__] your friend [__] your
friend I'm telling you what you need to
do get on stage every [__] night
after you do two spots then do me a
favor then come to the store and you can
have a drink yeah but until you do what
if I only do one then you're not going
to the [__] store you didn't deserve
to go to the store The Improv or the
Laugh Factory wherever you're going to
go to sit there and watch and learn from
[__] comedians you know and
that's what I'm saying like me and Sam
and [__] Kira we'd see each other
every night back in the 90s we had to
learn how to do this [__] and we go up
[__] all the time man that's how it
[__] works I have I didn't start at
the store [__] nobody does nobody
[__] does I you know when when I
started working with Lee about two
months before I met Lee a kid contacted
me Silent Bob his brother Rancho Bob
rcho Rancho Bob what does Rancho mean he
works on a ranch or some [__] okay
Rancho Bob works for Gabriel for a few
weeks but Rancho
Bob would go to Gabriel's shows take
some pictures and then go back to
Gabriel and give him pictures and
Gabriel go okay what you going been
doing he go frame these what I don't
know what happened and Gabriel would
give him like 20000 bucks well one day I
guess he saw that one of the comics was
getting a th000 bucks and he got pissed
off why is this com meting getting a
th000 bucks I'm taking pictures here
just as long as he is I want a th000
bucks so he went and ask Gabriel like
Gabriel told him to go [__] himself
Gabriel's like are you [__] kidding
me you came to me from day one from
school photography kid was going to film
school right I felt bad for the kid you
know he was trying to make his way going
to different comedy clubs taking
pictures of
comics I asked him one day I said can
you do me a favor can you come out to
the house and take some head shot of me
give him a 100 bucks he he almost his
head almost [__] blew up if I showed
you what he brought me back for head
shot I just threw him in the garbage
right didn't ask him for his 100 back
I just knew that this kid did not
prepare he didn't even know what a head
shot was when most people go let me see
what a head shot looks like right but a
year later he calls me back and he goes
listen I want to I'm going to film
school I'm graduating I want to help out
you know with videos I said all right
come on up and show shoot a joey karate
video he comes up spends an hour shoots
the video do you know this [__]
put it up without editing it even the
takes even the [__] like no next take
like I couldn't believe it this Rancho B
I couldn't believe it to the point you
hear what you're saying that I couldn't
believe it to the point that again I
couldn't say nothing you think it was
like a joke no he just didn't know L he
just was that you know he didn't do his
homework this is a kid that went to film
school this is why film school and all
these things mean dick to me yeah they
mean nothing to me he just threw away
money if I'm 18 right now and I want to
go to film school I go tell my dad
listen save the $10,000 for college buy
me a $2,000 camera and I'll go shoot
[__] everything for a year absolutely
for a year you go shoot you get yourself
a job at night you go shoot everything
be a PA anyone can be a PA he keeps
shooting videos keep shooting videos
keep shooting videos keep shooting
videos keep shooting videos and then you
become a PA because now you see it from
a different angle you learn the steps as
it goes along you thought you were
supposed to do this [__] you're
supposed to do this yeah and it becomes
an education and I want that guy I'll
run with that guy at four years than
some guy that comes from USC [__]
film school yeah you know eight six
years ago I did a a film for some guy
from USC Film School it was a $100 a day
film which to me I don't even give a
[__] about those it was like a film to
get financing for another film yeah do
you know when when I booked the film
this [__] I was shooting like a
Tuesday this [__] sent me an
email going okay we're going to rehearse
every day from 8: to 4:00 on this scene
I said listen not in my [__] world
you might as well cancel me now this is
$100 a day yeah it's and I listen Le and
that days when you're doing rehearsing
you're only days yeah we were shooting
like on a Tuesday the like let's say I
booked it today okay I booked it today I
got the call today Thursday this
[__] called me he's like hi uh
what we're going to do is we're going to
rehearse next Monday they go popping a
rehearse dog unless it's daero something
like that I'm not going down there to to
passadena from 8:00 in the morning to
4:00 no money Lee just rehears for a
[__] movie no no le no le let me tell
you the story I told him right on the
phone no and he was like you know I'm
very disappointed well be disappointed I
have a life I'm a stand up comic I do
this and this and this I don't have time
to rehearse from 8 to 4: that's not my
bag look at my resume look at the real
if you want to do this I'll play the
mobster not I understand not for the 100
a day okay when I got there next day we
did a good job and he came over like the
next Tuesday and he was like how you
doing that was very nice but guess what
they got the financing for the movie
didn't call me didn't call the other guy
didn't call anybody who shot that movie
that was there working hard all day for
a hundred bucks see do you understand me
my [__] tell him to go [__] himself
didn't make a difference he wasn't going
to hire us anyway when he got the finan
right then he oh no no then it gets
better this douchebag calls one day and
says hey what are you doing next weekend
nothing what or movie got into the Las
Vegas Film Festival into the finals we'd
like for you to come up okay call me
back with the flight information Hotel
I'm staying in you know me
dog right or wrong man I'm not you're
right Le and look how I did it I didn't
say are you nothing you just assume you
just steamroll okay I'll come look at do
me a favor it's a vacation for me and my
wife send me a plane ticket no don't
even say send me a plane ticket just say
send me let me know let me let me know
the info all the plane and reservation
info El right there you'll hear like a
[__] hello and you hear like what
yeah oh no no we were just thinking we
did the movie listen right there was
when I said listen you're in no [__]
danger I ain't spending dime wood I got
$90 after this because I got 100 for the
day and 10 goes to your agent right and
after you pay taxes it's $63 [__]
dollars yeah so now you want me to spend
two bills for a plane ticket and a hotel
and put a suit on and dry clean it to
come to your [__] Premiere you
understand me about Bley I'd rather go
to a museum I said it I said it in the
[__] beginning I told him no in the
beginning so he knew all the way through
I told him no from the rehearsal guess
what in 2000 I would have been there all
week from 8 to 4: like an [__] do you
follow me you learn you [__] learn
you get burnt you know all those $100
Day movies you shoot them you wear your
own suit you get there at 4 in the
morning you have no place to change you
change in a car like a [__] you know
like a homeless person and they make you
all these promises is that the end once
that scene is shot and you go home my
brother try to get your [__] real
from these people yeah exactly don't
hang up on you they'll do everything so
why am I going the extra mile for you
you you understand if you don't say no
in the beginning with these dummies yeah
don't [__] in the [__] ass out of
here they really will they're rookies
they're amateurs they don't know what
they're doing no that's what they're
built to do that's what these people do
that's what they get off on they get off
on [__] uh you know let's what we'll
get Le we'll give him $200 for the day
but he we'll get 800 for him right we'll
sub Le out for $ 800 well he's a radio
person you know what you sub Le off for
$800 you go to Lee Like a Man and go Lee
they're can I give me $ 800 for you do
you me if I give you five and I take
three and you say give me six and take
two done 200 for booking
you these [__] want to give you
two and keep six yeah I did a college
and uh
s whatever Barber last week yeah kid who
booked it for years kind of K yeah I
always knew didn't take a genius he's
Russian I am you know those
Russians kinky kid oh he calls himself
Russian you
know uh I just knew it just knew it from
[__] being out there you know like
something's not right here the college
paid this really College I'll do it it's
a Saturday I got nothing else but that's
weird you know
there's a guy that strictly does that I
don't even know if I want to mention his
name but he goes around to colleges and
he's he keeps like 80 and gives the
comics 20% yeah you know it's Lee so I
go up there this time first off I do two
things with him and both things they end
up all right but then something's not
right yeah something's not right the
check something so I find out he opens
up a comedy club and this is right after
Santa Barbara the shootings up there I
got a call like a week later he's doing
benefits 100% go to the shooting victims
Joey come help out and usually I do all
the benefits but I know this
[__] you know what I'm saying I
know him I just know people I know who
does comedy For the Love of comedy and I
know who does comedy to Rob other Comics
yeah there's a point in life where
comedians are go [__] it I'm miserable
nobody gives me a chance I'm going to
start becoming a producer and [__]
these Comics up Robin comics dude Rob
comics and they'll go to a hotel with a
big budget go give me$ ,000 a week and
they'll pay three Comics $100 and walk
with
$1,700 and this goes on until they and
they all get busted and they lose face
completely so don't even answer that
just tell them I'm headed to [__]
Jupiter unless you're coming I ain't
answer it's not so LMA it's [__] up
sometimes like a lot of job applications
now will say right depending on
experience or the H when you apply what
what's your desired rate I always felt
like if I I put I could put too little
and they'd be like scamming me they'd be
like oh we would have paid this much for
that position I always hated when they
did that no you put what you want so
when you go in the room they'll tell you
where you stand and then you have a
platform but at least you have somewhere
to start always hit them a little high
you have nothing to [__] lose so this
kid I know he's K he calls me up for
this
benefit and you know me I said let me
get back to you let me look at my
schedules there's no way I'm doing that
[__] you know do work too hard for
you take my [__] money it's not going
to get donated you're worse than White
Cliff Jean I know these people you know
White Cliff Jean robbed his own [__]
people with his benefits he's going to
be president too you know is he really
going to be presid he was before that
happened until he got caught robbing his
own [__] thing
so I find I get to the gig that night
and I go where's the guy and they're
like oh he doesn't book it no more he
just makes calls for us now and he gets
a few comics and he looked the kid
looked at me he goes things weren't
running so smooth look at the amount of
your check tonight look what you were
getting he goes he was taking the
difference guys he was taking two
quarters of the [__] check he got
from the college and then and then I go
yeah he called me I go I always knew he
was a thief he called me for those
benefits he goes was he scamming people
with those benefits cuz what he was
doing was he went to a bar and made the
bar a deal that I want 50% of everything
the bar the drinks the food the door he
got a 100 people in there but he CED the
door he only got five people to pay for
tickets so he would keep the hundred
bucks and get 50% of the door so he
wasn't donating a dime he was donating a
100 bucks but keeping 3,000 instead of
get it to the comedian there's always a
move with this [__] guy yeah that's
[__] up hey man the best thieves rob
you with a gun when somebody robs you
with a gun they're a [__] [__]
because there's a million ways to Rob
[__] without a [__] gun let
me give some shout outs here we get this
party started steal one of their checks
out of their trash that's how you
[__] go take one of the credit cards
you want a cookie I had a cookie
Michelle Hurley I love you Nick letis
you backcock sucker Teddy Lynch Jamie
Mel I don't even know what the [__] this
name is Seth Mell mjt Squire Eddie G
Travis what the [__] is this my man my
main man Ted Shay and [__] same as it
ever was podcast making things [__]
happen I love you [__] suck as always so
yeah you know you always got to keep it
together what's up Le you ain't that hot
oh you're a liar he's faking it look at
him he's Faking It faking I'm a big
Faker what uh what do you got working on
my brother what do you got coming up
what do you want to do what are your
goals for this year's 20 I'm going to do
a special I got a production company to
do a special we're going to tape the
[__] do an hour around town and
I'm just gearing up for that getting
that hour together going to do some
sit-ups are you going get beautiful you
taping at one location yeah yeah at the
U I think the Virgil on Santa Monica
we'll have some dates for you soon G to
get that [__] together how is the ver a
nice place yeah it's nice man that place
around the corner by the gym they've
been shooting a lot of specials there
like El Portal or right there Port F
down lers or something yeah who shot
lately there uh Sarah Colona and then a
couple other
people very nice I want to do it all
though man who's that dude from that TVS
show the the
the Suns show the cele and Sun show the
white dude right he shot there Owen
Benjamin yeah Owen at the Port out
theater very nice yeah it's very nice
Wendy Leeman shot there a few years ago
very nice we should do a podcast
da what else you want to do this year so
you're shooting that when when are your
ATA I got a I we got to book it but I
don't know I'm thinking around like may
I want like a good thre Monon chunk to
just get ready and [__] hone it every
day you know what I mean
my teeth in it's tough it really is
tough yeah but it's good to have a date
to shoot for instead of just like oh I'm
going to work on my standup in general
can't wait to have a date can't wait to
have a date once you strap that date on
it [__] with your head oh yeah yeah
yeah you got to get ready you don't want
to look dumb up there you want every
second of it to be [__] beautiful
it's tough that's why I never committed
to one because I know it's a lot of
[__] work I'm trying to commit to one
now we won't know anything till
mid-march and then I got two months but
I got a big chunk I got three weeks in a
row to pick up another 15 minutes yeah
well you should do it man you done a
couple CDs right then I'll be here for a
month and then I'll tighten all the
business stuff I'm going to hire a
production managers I don't have to
worry about Dick yeah I don't want to
hear [__] dick from nobody right and
then I'll probably shoot in Vegas at the
South Point Casino aw we Lis say'll be
there with a tuxedo eating these [__]
Edibles passing them [__] door I'll
catch a ride with Lee man that's how
this [__]
roll [__] just like that Lee just like
thatly those Russian neighbors must not
know what's going on in this in this
office they're like having a party when
we came in yeah can you imagine what
they're thinking when they hear the
stuff that comes out of here I think
there's like a [__] dog ring in here
[__] [__] fights and [__] you know a
lot of comedians like you when I mention
your name you're one of the ones that's
very well liked it's uh I I was going to
tell you that in the phone but I want
your head to get swollen it's it's
really nice having you around like
D you man and you just have this warm uh
thing to you I see you I see guys like
Steve Simone I see a lot of young guys
and I'm like man those guys are in limbo
right now right the same limbo I was at
for years spinning around not knowing
and when you get down about it you just
go [__] it let me go do a spot let me
work with it and everything involves you
kind of Le you got to lean into it you
got to [__] if if you're getting like
bummed out about your career [__] put
more work into it instead of like
sitting back and going why isn't
anything happen cuz it'll distract you
and you'll [__] actually love doing
it too that's what you forget you're
going to love writing you're going to
love performing [__] it's it's beautiful
to see a joke grow yeah it really is to
see a joke grow that you were [__]
around with Lee in the car and we would
say say that up on stage and I said it
then you had a tag to it another tag
then it becomes something else then you
had a tag to that and now you have a
full bit you know and you're like [__] I
did this you know AB just going out and
and sometimes you want to sit down and
really write but sometimes you really do
do your best writing on stage I think I
lied to myself and now I'm trying to be
honest with myself it's great if I put
thoughts down on paper and connect them
a certain way but then when you get to
the club and you get there and you see
her performing in front of you the
person in front of you it all comes to
you while you're hearing somebody else's
Cadence you get to that Rhythm and
you're like oh this is what I'm going to
[__] say and next thing you know you
go on stage you just wrote this
two-minute little bit to open up the
show yeah but you did it you know it's
it's that's what I like about this yeah
and you see people's faces and you're
like oh they need something now like
here's something funny here's something
funny you just keep you know they need
it so you're pulling it out of the
[__] Sky it's beautiful love I love
it I love this morning I got up at like
5:30 I went outside I put some coffee on
I went outside smoked some Pond I went
and I just started writing thoughts you
know and and I think when I write those
thoughts and then I write out my
thoughts for the day in a different
notebook in the morning and then usually
after breakfast
I put a couple entries into like a a
chapter in a book I'll just write it
even if I redo a sentence and put three
sentences I'm good because I exercise
that muscle that's the thing you know so
now if I go on stage that exercise I did
in the afternoon with that performance
at the comedy store with the pressure
and who you have to follow it just it
makes you a better [__] absolutely I
really believe that I really believe
that since I've been back at The Comedy
Store I've grown as a comic I've grown
as a comic when I go to the gym it's
amazing how much goes into being a good
comic and a mediocre comic and I know
now because I see how easy it is now and
years ago I didn't do any of these
things right I didn't go for a walk you
know lately I've been walking to the
weed store four or five blocks who gives
a [__] when I get in the car and lose my
parking spot I walk and it's nice you
know I go to the gym I I I do 10
different things you know don't you find
like a bunch of ideas pop into your head
when you're walking or running or
exercising like just beautiful ideas
that's why I do what I do yeah that's
why I go to the [__] gym and I have a
my agent gave me a little pad that I
carry now mhm and I go to the gym
sometimes and I'll have it with me so I
can just write even if it's one word to
remind me of that thought yeah I I put I
put um ideas into this phone all day
long on my voice recorder first thing I
do in the morning bust it out well I
make not but if I'm in the gym I don't
bring the phone in yeah of course CU I
don't want the phone to ring because
when you're on the elliptical or you're
lifting and you're walking to get water
and you listen to the music and the
music's playing in your head yeah and
you start thinking it breaks you down it
makes you I always believe when you work
out early like 12 or 11 it makes you
that much better I used to go in the
pool at 6 yeah that makes you sharper
than F the pool is a [__] I'm getting
back into the pool I'm getting you jump
in a [__] pool at 6:00 in the morning
by 8 your mind is [__] just machine
gunning thoughts I used to swim for two
hours a day as a kid and like that was
like crazy discipline and and I uh I'm
getting a car on Wednesday I'm going to
start going to the pool again every day
it just [__] it wears you down it
gets rid of all your stress and just
that discipline of it all man can't
those waterproof earphones oh they have
those now yeah they got some waterproof
earphones or something right have you
seen them some I haven't but they
probably do it wouldn't surprise me look
that up look it up I can't type that
right now look that's not going to
happen our Tech gu is always stuned look
at the [__] shamp you're lucky I love
love you like I did second what am I
going to do with you I have no
idea you look good though God bless you
you look beautiful you for your burger
[__] you gain any weight over the
weekend no we we maintained thank God
you stay at the same we had to go to the
gym both days yeah all three days look
at you so you go to the gym every day
basically I usually take one day off a
week I try to but sometimes I just what
what are you and the wife doing this
weekend I don't know about next weekend
it's light this weekend that's it
that's you're out of [__] Loop
between San Diego and Valentine's
between bir it was Christmas her
birthday was like January 29th and then
Valentine's Day it's like [__] and you
got taken for your lungs this year the
three days of San Diego no we split that
she's really Co about that get the [__]
out she don't even work split that you
go for [__] everything you come back
on Sundays with bunny rabbit is and [__]
I pay I pay for the food usually but
even that sh she's really cool I got
really lucky you're got really lucky
you're a good [__] man look at you no
[__] suck I used to pay for
everything I I almost broke up with a
girl because of it one time yeah she
just never ever said thank you I just
grew up in a situation where I said
thank you for everything right and I
actually don't know what to do and I'm
not my mom's not mad at Paula but my mom
sent Paula a birthday a birthday card
with a little gift in it and Paula
didn't write her back and from I used I
remember when we used to go buy suits my
mom would make us write thank you notes
to the
salesman and I wrote thank you notes I
wrote I wrote thank you notes basically
up until I moved here cuz I sent a
couple never heard back for R so I got
discouraged but Paula grew up in
Englewood her mom doesn't always even
get her gifts and she just doesn't it's
not that she's being rude but I don't
know if I should say hey my mom would
appreciate it thank you car did you call
a how about a [__] call what's a card
what's with the card what yeah so it's
over now because now your mom has a like
to stand
on this is the things you have to say to
her January she loves Paula right yeah
but not until you don't [__] call me
back to say something nice did you put a
check in there for Paula a little gift
card yeah okay then what the [__] man
yeah you know you got to have a little
[__] cool too you got to say Lee hey
my mom call her back or call your mom
and put her on that's your job you know
if she don't [__] know you got to
educate her you know she's an attorney
she better [__] start R thank you
cards and Char for everything this is
just common sense the reason why people
didn't answer you is because between you
and I nobody does that no more right did
it for I do it for everything when I
went to prison when I got out I wrote
the judge for [__] 10 years I wrote
the [__] judge okay and to let him
know my progress so his his efforts
didn't feel like they were in vain right
you know when I walk into an audition
whether I eat [__] or not I don't even h
i don't even erase the audition from the
computer cuz I have his address that's
how I erase it I'm only allowed to erase
it so when I get back from the audition
I look at my wife I'll be right back I
go right into the room I don't give a
[__] what's going on I fill out the
thank you card and I put on the mantle
so it goes out the next day so there's
no misunderstanding I don't do it later
as I walk up the stairs I'm thinking
about you know this is something that
it's a natural Rel you know and this is
our problem as as human beings we blame
everything well she's from [__]
Compton who gives a [__] where she's
from I don't give a [__] she's from Mars
these are the things you have to know or
you have to say something like yeah so
your mom can't be mad at Paula she's
type of confused nobody's [__] sent
her a [__] card with an envelope of
money so she in her mind she doesn't
know where it's coming from like where
what do I do next so I sympathize so it
takes a you to go call my mother and
thank her for the [__] card please
and yeah it's really so don't have to
[__] I don't know what to say you
know what the [__] to say you're an
attorney what do you do when you go to
court what are you going to tell the
[__] guy I don't know what to say no
you know what to say d thank you I
enjoyed it I bought a nice pair of shoes
for [__] school yeah that's the
that's I bought some manners nobody has
ever I think going to break up with me I
said that I think no no no Lee you have
to do this because there's people that
go around listen man three years ago I
grew up with this family that was a
class family when I grew up I mean they
were like the hierarchy of the Town yeah
very classy Town nice people when you
walked in the house they offered you a
glass of water I don't know how many
meals I had there I'll do anything for
them right they called me about two
years ago Le knows and they said my
nephews out there could you show them a
good time I did one better I got him a
hotel room that I pay two days out of my
pocket for him cuz I didn't want him in
the house with the cats and the baby
yeah you know when you're
21 you don't a [__] about babies right I
feel you you know what I'm saying but
uh I I I I never saw anything like that
after two days and I wanted him to stay
four days he's from my hometown yeah now
one thank you to my wife o listen I
don't give a [__] what Madness you got
towards me I feel you yeah I'm nobody to
tell a 21y old what to do right oh my
wife hands you a bowl of food you don't
even look at her we got a problem
finally the second day I pulled him as
sign they go do me a favor would my wife
gives you something say thank you right
he looked at me like I was from another
planet but between you and I I don't
think he knew I think well he must not
have I think mother loved him so much
that never corrected that fault sure you
know what with me I don't have time come
here for a second go over and say
[__] thank you yeah the [__] is wrong
with you yeah come and say thank you or
not a lot of times I judge nine out of
10 comics when I was in BR I could have
gave a comic $10 and said down I chopped
that thing up three ways the feat got
the same thing the next day when I wake
up on my Facebook or my email better be
a [__] thank you well there better be
a call at 901 saying thank you if there
isn't I ain't mad at you yeah but I know
I think I actually did call you about
that 91 901 and you got to know I
usually don't even call but like that
was so cool I did people this is
something that you do uh I was telling
something the other day when when people
call you up and go I have a job for you
you have to audition I've heard coms go
[__] Matt filtron he's making me
audition dog if lisak called me and he
got me an audition even if I didn't get
it he thought of me exactly he put his
word up for me right he went to a cast
and say hey man your party ain't going
to start unless you get Joe in here what
I'm looking for a penguin looking guy
perfect whatever get him in here you
don't know what you're [__] looking
for it's uh and I'm not I'm not putting
you down Le we're not putting your
girlfriend down I'm putting you down
this is like what I told you that you're
killing yourself the whole time because
you won't say nothing this like having a
child that does what he wants and you
don't say no we're not going to no
[__] Museum today you know you Hey
listen we're not doing this today listen
we went out to this place now I got to
drive for an to a concert I don't even
know these [__] people why am I doing
this I don't listen to these people why
am I doing this and somebody would go
you're right this isn't about you right
or wrong I don't give a [__] if I go to
Terry you want to do something no it's
not for her yeah this is why I've always
been a big advocate for earphones when I
have my Black Sabbath on you're not
going to hear it but when you have that
jumping Jew music on I don't want to
hear it either so make sure you got your
earphones
on yeah now you're in a pickle cuz now
it's been two weeks she got the card
yeah so now so tomorrow next it's not
too late no it's not too late next but
thank thankfully my mom's card got
delayed and she felt really bad about it
so so she what my mom's card got delayed
so she felt really bad about it so I
think I I got a couple weeks to save it
I'll just tell her tomorrow tell let
know when you see it go you got to call
not not like listen I think no not like
what I just told you with the ticket
assume the clothes you know assume the
clothes means hand to the phone yeah you
have to call my mother here call my
mother right what are you talking about
call my mother than thaning for the car
we're not Savages here and she'll look
at you you know and tell her that we're
not [__] Savages here we not Savages
bro we're human
beings you got to [__] call you got
to call and say thank you that's that
goes so much oh because and I tell you
when it goes
long when you go shopping when you shop
for a house or when you shop for a car
that's what's going to make the
difference not the guy that calls you
and says hey Lee come on down I got the
manag to do a deal it's guy goes Le I'm
not calling you I just want you to know
I want you to make sure you got all the
information you're looking for to make
this decision do you have the pamphlet
yes I do thank you thank you for coming
in guess what as soon as I'm clicking
that phone I'm looking the envelope with
his think you know I'm walking up to the
corner and delivering it so when he gets
home from work tomorrow Joey Diaz is on
his [__] mind again tomorrow that's
what this whole you know that we're
missing because everybody's on the
computer nobody around around to tell
them nobody wants to tell your kids
anymore how to [__] act like nobody
really wants to I see it I see it when I
go to you know I see how kids behave
kids the parents sit there ha on the Tex
thing I want to [__] end this yeah I
want to end the smartphone I want to end
the smartphone because it's making us
Dumber we are missing life yeah we are
missing pieces of Life go anywhere now I
I uh I went to uh the mall with the baby
us I got off the plane from M I went to
the mall with the baby the wife it's
Valentine's Day the baby runs around
this thing there my wife gets Chipotle
at the mall and I got the protein
smoothie the slim down and I make the
best of it you know what I'm saying
sometimes we get the pizza at Joe some
it's a quick thing there's always
parking right up front because it's
Sunday nobody goes early I usually go
early like 9:30 10 what was I talking
about I don't even know talking about
correspond
smartphones I know you made fun of the
of the museum but we went there and it
was like some really cool South americ
stuff seeing the stuff that was from
like 700 AD that people made with rocks
and tools dwarfed anything I could ever
make yeah but how good was Instagram
back then [__] terrible did you take
one of those tools to stab yourself in
the [__] eyeball no but I'm you
should have [__] done what point who
gives a
[__] who gives a [__] at the end of the
week how does it affect your [__]
life when you go to [__] shop when
you come here to make gas how does it
affect your life seeing two spoons from
South America great that's [__] great
that's not my point what's your point
that people back then without the
smartphones and stuff could do all this
amazing stuff and that's right yeah
that's right because we're stuck in this
[__] dumb phone anywhere you go
people are missing life you know
somebody asked me this weekend you don't
tweet all day why would I want to do
that I'm missing life why don't give a
[__] I'm reporting life to you live your
[__]
life gotten to I tweet in the mornings I
tweet in the mornings sometimes at night
to tell about the podcast get people
going
night the week is over cuz a lot of
people wake up Monday I'm H over no you
shouldn't have been H over it's [__]
you know I see all these people cry but
then they cry everybody's crying I don't
get it how the [__] are you H what
happened to Sunday night yeah what
happened to Sunday night well you didn't
prepare you have a week in front of you
you have to prepare on Sunday [__]
week trust me I used to go out to the
store and do blow then I wake up on
Mondays and when my life was in shambles
because I didn't prepare for the week
there was no preparation for [__]
Monday these are all little things that
you uh you got to do you got to get your
[__] together [__] see this is why in
today's society you don't send your kid
to college because the first year
they've been
so uh socially robbed they're so
socially robbed of the social what's
really going on you know do you think if
if you didn't have a mom or a dad and
you you were working for eight bucks an
hour do you think you'd be at that
[__] Museum
no I don't [__] think so I got
problem it's the it's
the we like I just said wasted [__]
time yeah no it's four years of of like
Prime Time gone and this is what I'm
looking at now as a 52 year old I'm
trying to pass on to Lee and pass on to
other people there's so many things that
you think are so important when you're
26 at the end of the day they don't
[__] matter when you when they're
[__] [__] you in the ass evicting
you from house what are you going to
tell them I went to see what these
people doing in 700 AD in
Columbia do you get it we we have our
minds somewhere else but then we don't
we get pissed off when things aren't
going our way like man I want more well
you're [__] around this is what's
going on this is and this is what goes
on all over the [__] place I did it
for 15 years I said I told you guys I
wanted headline but you don't want to go
out and feature for free you know what
I'm saying I had all these expectations
but but I didn't do want to do what what
was in front of me what was necessary to
do what's in front of me my old partner
in crime you know the podcast is what's
in front of you cut the thing and put it
up no well I have to go to this place
and do an interview who gives a [__]
about your interview the podcast needs
to go up that's what's in front of you
you're avoiding it I [__] hate going
to Jiu-Jitsu dog cuz I know I'm just
going to get beat up and S but I go in
there anyway because I know eventually
I'm going to get better after a while
one day my mind's going to click and go
you're not going to get beat up no more
going to start sweeping [__]
and that's absolutely right this is it
this is what we do people so stop your
[__] crying life ain't going how you
want it to [__] go do something about
it close the gaps close the [__] gaps
I get all these emails and life ain't
going how you're supposed to go you're
lucky no there's no luck involved
There's 7 days a week 70 hours a [__]
week yeah 70 hours a week you know when
I first and don't get me started on
National Anthem it's President's Day you
sacks of [__] [__] get up get
up it's a beautiful day to be alive it
may be 100 in turn that into a [__]
snowball and eat it what the [__] is
wrong with you at least you're getting
snow the East Coast stop your [__]
crying you bad [__] get up get
the flag shovel get a heart attack you
[__] what is this thing with Governor
Christie [__] telling people you
can't knock on people's doors and shovel
it's free right you got to shovel you
got to make a [__] living [__]
what you put this s for I'm too high for
the national an today you [__] we didn't
even plan it for President's Day I
forgot it was President's Day [__] I
forgot it was [__] pres cuz we're too
busy working we don't take days off giv
a
[__] give a [__] I that's the goddamn
truth cuz that's church when I was a kid
on this day I go to Harlem glow tries
every [__] year yeah my mother would
take me to the Harem this is it the
Monday after because it would be my
birthday next weekend you see how I roll
I don't [__] around Lisa here you don't
what do you got tomorrow Le how you
feeling my brother I'm [__] up I got
fluid in my ear from my shower I got to
put a Q-tip in my ear after I take a
shower and I [__] forget and the
[__] fluid just sits there like I'm
to it's kind of gross oh I hate like I'm
going to get that vertigo all over again
and [__] what do you got going on what
dates I want you to come back before you
[__] the special I will so we give you
all the support you are you're a I think
the best of your
funny I love you you [__] cracked me
up the pieces you Cookie I didn't put up
my podcast today how you going to grow
up to be big you put up your podcast I
put up my podcast how's it doing
congratulations I haven't looked up the
numbers yet I wrote a Blog and then I
put up a podcast which Matt did a while
ago and about to put up congratulations
brother I'm proud yeah man thanks I was
it's uh hard that's how you keep from
waiting at Denny's tell them what your
fear was it was just
uh it's it's a it's a lot to commit to
and it's a lot I I had a vision for what
I wanted to do well not a vision I had a
I I've learned a lot from working on a
bunch of different podcasts and I
thought there was a way to do something
and I saw and I I just didn't want it to
not do well oh who cares so I've been
I've been putting it off and putting it
off but I put it up today just put it
out and it grows just grows over the
years yeah like I told them I said
listen you'll never know until you put
it up and if it's not good in the
beginning you just keep tweaking it you
get it better better better and you
tweak it and that's what this whole
podcast thing is about yeah we weren't
doing good for a long [__] time but
we stuck it out at 6:00 in the morning
yeah and we made our [__] point you
know and that's uh that's part of this
whole [__] thing beautiful man
congratulations dude congrat really is
awesome doing a Blog is tough
too well thank you is it no but but I'm
doing two a month oh no I'm doing dude
slow down I'm doing two podcasts I'm not
doing a podcast every week you're doing
a Blog two blogs a month and then two
podcast a month dude and I slow
down you're going to kill yourself I
know it's too much um but Joey called me
this morning and told me to write a blog
put it out and I I had started one like
four or five days ago but I just
couldn't it's hard to know what to say
like it's it's hard to put you point
across without sounding weird or ah you
do your best that's the thing it's a
Blog you're not working for anybody
there's no real consequences to not
doing a perfect blog I miss your blog I
know you're too I know it's busy it's
your world it's your world whatever you
write in the blog on a weekly level it's
your [__] world exactly it's more
it's better the idea is that it comes
out not that it's perfect it comes out
all the time listen man if you want to
do something at home a Blog a podcast
look at Pat sh does a podcast people
doing all type of things you know what
who gives a [__] if three people listen
just be the best podcast you can for
those three people yeah that's it who
gives a [__] about iTune ratings you're
getting your voice out there you're
getting your life out there you're
putting your heart out there if you
really putting your heart out there
people will feel it they feel it if
you're faking the funk listen you're
we're all not going to be [__] great
podcasters we're all going to think it's
radio at first but like you said 10
years you find your voice you know Lee's
finding his voice on a
podcast it all evolves man but it's
better than not doing anything who gives
a [__] listen who's interesting who's
really interesting it's so much better
than not doing anything it's like Leaps
and Bounds ahead of I know people come
up to me and they tell me it's s like
I'm not an interesting person what do
you mean get an interesting you do
something that's very interesting you
just don't sell it you think you look
down on what you do right you know I
think somebody who fixes a car is
interesting why cuz I can't [__] do
it yeah I can't do it I can't change a
flat I can change one takes me two and a
half hours and [__] by that time the
[__] guy comes on the TR truck on the
405 and helps you from the state yeah
you didn't even call them just like you
look like [__] out there I got to stop
and help you they really do have a great
service here in LA but please people you
have something you want to put out there
it's free yeah blogger.com free I don't
give a [__] if every week on Monday you
just put out it's going to be a great
week these are the things I'm going to
do and blog it and I guarantee people
will start reacting to you going you
know what I need to do that I don't I
don't want to do that though I got a bu
you good comments on it it was cool yeah
Lee trust me because people see people
already like you man who gives a [__]
what you're right or you know I I love
it when you write a blog that's
heartfelt and you spell a word wrong and
there's 10 idiots you spell whatever
really this is what you got out of it
this is why you're on the computer 10
hours you're a [__] loser because
this is what you look for as a fault
instead of looking for somebody's Beauty
in their [__] blog or somebody's
Beauty in their dish they brought up
from Columbia on a [__] Saturday for
Lee to go down there and look at it you
lucky I love you [__] if not you'd
be on the 170 with a [__] plank roll
on your head right now [__]
out there with three hookers I got dead
out there right next to them got a group
of people dead I got three or four
[__] people that got confused out
there by the 170 by Sherman Way now you
get some editing to do on top of it all
every time I go out there's a hand
sticking out you see the hand with the
skin growing
away little r remember that [__]
thought she was [__] cute speaking of
cute Iron Dragon TV the best classic
martial arts films at your [__]
fingertips Stam Iron Dragon TV has the
best in classic martial arts series from
The yit Man series to [__] all the
early Jackie Chan listen I know a lot of
people are into these type of films if
this is what you're into this is the uh
Roku channel for you iron dragon TV say
the code word Joey oh [__] we type it in
and get two free [__] movies to
start off okay they add movies every day
they're adding the 4K technology pretty
soon we're going to be doing a Roku
channel on their on their Network so
please support Iron Dragon TV go there
right now even if you don't get the two
movies tonight see what they got get
your dick hard for the weekend again
what are you press brother you press
Joey Joey and you get two free [__]
films movies are so good they'll make
your dick hard they'll make your dick
hard number two for Optimum optimization
I was just there this weekend I'll tell
you man on it is making things happen
they really [__] are Aubrey is an
unadulterated genius to the [__] Mex
that's all I got to tell you
[__] all right you want to
start getting your mind right Your Heart
Right your breathing right everything it
starts with H optimization go to hit.com
right now and press in church and get
10% off your first order go with Alpha
Brain I'm sick and tired of telling you
[__] this once you do it you're
not coming back it's like a finger in
the ass of heroin number two hit E6 the
best cigar on the market guaranteed
1,200 [__] Puffs there ain't a
cigarette or [__] thing device at
7-Eleven or any other these vapor stores
that's going to give you 1,200
guaranteed Puffs that's like 10 [__]
cigarettes okay 10 cigarettes are $7 a
piece at the [__] E it's $70 you get
these for $20 minus 20% off no only do
they have the cigar flavor they have
nicotine from 24 to zero so you get off
the [__] cig like Lee said even if
it's February you can't get your
residuals down it don't matter we're
there for you h.com go there right now
and press in church oh [__] and get 20%
off your order right now so this is $20
it's $16 for
$1,200 guaranteed [__] hits okay
where you going to get that type of
action from go to hit6 right now and
press in Joy there you go 20% off and
while we're on it my [__] Primo is
over there at nailed life these
[__] will destroy you with all
their [__] dabbing products they got
tremendous vapor pens they got the
sticks to put the wax into the [__]
torch with it they got torches they got
[__] everything go to nail life.com
get one of those [__] vapor
pens get 20% off what are they press in
the Box Joey oh [__] oh [__] and I
guarantee if you're into dabbing and
seeing the devil and blow torches and
blowing [__] up you on love nail
life.com right now go there right now
Iron Dragon nailed toif on it.com and H
sigs [__] that's how we do it
here boom how you feeling brother you
going to finish this cookie no God
you're crazy what you going to do you're
whittling away man you better eat that
cookie some more weed but he
want I'm cool though Lee wants to go to
bed Lee ain't going to bed Le you got to
put that air conditioning on it's hot
than [__] here I'm cold oh my God
look at me I'm sweating up a storm I
ain't want too many Edibles and my
estrogen's coming out of my head I think
he was got chili in here are you chilly
Willie I'm fine how many piece of that
cookie have you eaten oh barely any of
it but I'm high as [__] really oh yeah I
see you every like 15 minutes I got no
tolerance man I see you every 15 minutes
just take listen I'm easing into it Joe
I can't be like look at this poor
bastard look how high he is oh he looks
great I've never seen anyone so happy
this poor bastard see that youe how many
milligrams tonight 40 no more than that
40 that's it that's not true 25 15 five
for the cookie 160 tops tops I only
think there's one level of these Stars I
think they're all 125 I I don't believe
the hype you're as tough as [__]
Nails even if they're 125 again I knew
it m what's your next date tell me yo uh
I think I'm going to be up in venturo
with Tom saguro March 11th so that'll be
a fun show March 11th at ventor County
Comedy Club V haror or something right
huh huh is it like ventor Harbor comedy
club something like that yeah okay there
you go I know [__] I see stuff happening
Indianapolis you bad [__] I'm
coming to you [__] next week oh
[__] what's the name of the club in
Indiana crackers crackers like a
[__] is that it February 26
through 28 don't [__] miss it be
there that's right or be square or be
square I love you guys want to thank
Matt fullron again I want to thank you
guys from the bottom of my heart for
watching listening having a good time
Lis I have for being a soldier as usual
getting high with us yeah podcast is
called flying to
radio the Jew is definitely flying
tonight that's for sure and he's going
to go home and do push-ups push-ups yeah
I'm trying to think I'm trying to think
of the menu I could concoct right now
there [__] menus in your life
[__] I love you guys thank you
very much for coming on tonight and
helping us out watching have a great
[__] week we'll see you Wednesday
afternoon go to on it.com need cob
Church to get 10% off all their
optimization products let me meet you
guys go to irondragon tv.com he's go Joe
to get 20 to get two free rentals sorry
of all the great Marshall Arts films go
to nailedit life.com and use codo Joey
Diaz to get 20% off the come me